- You just host...
You hosted one of my
favorite shows, actually
I love Eurovision-
- Eurovision.
- Eurovision 2023.
- Oh, my god.
- [Kelly] How was it
being a part of that show?
- [Hannah] Honestly, just insane.
- [Kelly] You grew up on it?
- Yeah, I totally grew up on it.
I'm from musical theater, for God's sake.
- Yeah, because I love Eurovision too,
with Will Ferrell and Rachel.
- Oh, my god.
- And Rachel.
- But they got that spot on.
- Yeah, I know.
But that's why I loved it.
- But they're have been some amazing guys
that have come outta that.
- Maneskin.
- I love Maneskin.
- Oh my god, I love them.
And then back in the
day we had Bucks Fizz.
I mean, which would never happen now.
Like a four people group, two girls.
And in one part of the song,
the guys whip the girls' skirts off
and they've got like minis.
And I was like, can you
imagine a woman going,
"Oh no, that's cool," now.
- Yeah, let's do it.
- Oh my God.
- I know.
But I think that's what's
so funny, like the...
Not funny, but just entertaining
is how outrageous it can get.
- That's the best part of it.
- Even Maneskin like, they're outrageous
in the way that they look like.
They're, first of all,
in a Vogue shoot time.
It's very theatrical, but their attire,
like, their aesthetic is cool.
And the songs are rad.
- Yeah.
- I mean, obviously, I
like ABBA, Celine Dion.
There's so many winners
from that show.
- Oh, my god.
That went on to do big things.
- I absolutely...
I mean, Celine Dion.
- Yeah.
- God, what we would've given
to hear her sing back then with that.
I mean, just incredible.
Yeah, so it's been quite overwhelming.
But I'd never worked
with an in-ear do-dah.
- I hate it.
- I am not the person for that.
- You know what, I do this...
- Yeah, you go, like-
- I look up.
And I'm just, like...
I hate... I literally begged-
- It's like, you're trying
to figure out who farted.
- Please don't do that.
(Kelly laughs)
- It's not good.
- It's not good for me either.
I don't do well.
- I have to stop myself going,
sorry, 180 million people,
"What?"
- Yeah.
- Awful.
- I didn't get used to it.
I didn't at all.
And then the crowd gets
so loud and you're like...
It almost sounds like
Charlie Brown's teacher,
"Wah, wah, wah, wah."
And you're like, I don't
understand what you're saying.
And we're on live television.
Anyway, it was a hit.